another day another onslaught of flight
disruptions for air Travelers
before 9 A.M eastern time on Monday
airports around the world were already
tallying more than 10 000 flight delays
and 1700 cancellations according to
FlightAware tracking data those numbers
could easily double by day's end
nearly 80 percent of people who have
taken an overnight trip outside their
local area this year have experienced at
least one travel related issue according
to a newbankrate.com survey these issues
include high prices long weights poor
customer service hard to find
availability lost money due to canceled
and disrupted plans or something else
with the July 4th holiday weekend now in
the rear view mirror Asia and Europe
have emerged as hubs of air travel
nightmares with flight cancellations and
delays surpassing levels seen recently
in the United States demonstrating the
global headwinds faced by the air travel
industry at seven Chinese airports more
than one in five flights were canceled
today on Monday in Australia 40 of
flights operated by Virgin Australia and
35 by the qantas-owned budget carrier
Jetstar were delayed as were 29 from
Australian flag carrier Qantas London's
Heathrow Airport canceled 60 flights
Monday and apologized for Rocky traveler
experience in a statement Heathrow is
blaming quote exponential growth in
passenger numbers end quote and is
signaling the need to cut even more
flights in weeks to come on Monday 30 of
flights out of London Gatwick Airport
were also delayed more than a quarter of
Air France flights have been delayed in
addition to 22 percent of Lufthansa
flights and 21 of British Airway flights
last week SAS the flag carrier of
Denmark Norway and Sweden filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy protection in the
United States one day after a thousand
of its Pilots called for a strike one
week later The Fallout continues today
the airline acts 75 of its total flight
volume according to FlightAware by
comparison operations in North America's
Airlines and airports look downright
sunny on Monday morning
with the exception of Air Canada where
18 of flights were delayed but the week
is still young
[Music]